this morning a special fourth of July
edition of the dish with Matt Moore more
as a cook musician pilot and author his
latest book is called cereal griller a
trip across America that makes you think
and makes you hungry with the help of
his small 1976 Piper Cherokee plane in
the air and countless car rides on the
ground Matt Moore traveled 10,000 miles
in three months to put together his
latest book it's a rolling grilling
guest party across America you were all
over America but it feels like a it
feels like a global book the greatest
part about where we are as we all come
from somewhere else and one of the
commonalities that we share is that we
bring our cuisines from Lillian's
barbecue in Atlanta to fajitas a go-go
in Houston and Zahav in Philadelphia if
you have a craving for any particular
style
it is easy to find in cereal griller
mores a hundred and twenty five recipe
tribute to fire and friendship first the
basics as Moore explains the
all-important difference between a
barbecue and grilling as a southerner we
often talk about the difference between
what is barbecue and what is grilling my
wife is from Wisconsin so I love her to
death but when she invited me to the
first summer barbecue there were
bratwurst and cheese which is not
technically barbecue as a southerner I'm
expecting slowly roasted pork or brisket
so everything in barbecue happens below
300 degrees but in serial griller we're
actually focusing on all the goodness
that happens above that temperature
where you're getting that natural
reaction of the sugars and the enzymes
to create that brown food is good food
mantra brown food is good food is
scientific says more he talks about the
mired reaction that chemical dance
between amino acids and sugars that
takes place when food is prepared above
300 degrees purists will always argue
for hard wood to produce that heat but
there are many ways to get there one of
the things that really wanted to strive
to do and writing this book is not
discriminate whether you're a gas grill
or a charcoal grill or hardwood
curler but being able to set up
different zones of fire this week for
the fourth of July more showed us a
feast let's talk about what's on the
table first yeah first in my hand a
little cocktail we picked this up in
Charleston South Carolina it's a day
tripper lemon juice vodka a little bit
of sweet tea extract and some lavender
bitters just feel right at home here and
before plate it down here all of it
fresh off a grill
three down ribs chicken thighs with herb
salsa octopus souvlaki two-step brought
sliders with mustard heirloom caprese
salad peach and Taleggio bruschetta
baked beans peach cobbler and corn with
feta dill butter and my family we have a
saying that feta makes it better so it's
a little bit of a dill and feta butter
that we just brushed that over the top
more currently lives in Nashville those
relatives are from Syria and Lebanon the
book is heavy with Middle Eastern and
Mediterranean influence part of what
leads more to constantly search for new
flavors and opportunities you're a
businessman a pilot a musician and a
cook yeah what's most important a family
actually more has five and three year
old girls back at home there's nothing
better than cooking vegetables and
getting them to eat their vegetables and
I'll tell you when I put it on a grill
it's a totally different experience it's
always clean plate club and my family so
getting together on a nightly basis and
passing along these recipes that I
learned growing up it's really a great
experience for me to pass on kind of
five-year-old girl who puts her chefs
excited and it's fun teaching them to
write sure sharing it with them yeah I
mean you know one of my favorite recipes
in the family we have is comes from the
Middle East kind of a stuffed grape
leave and if you ask my kids what their
favorite food is it's not pizza hot dogs
or hamburgers it's it's grape leaves
that's great but my mother has to make
him the way food like this can bring
family together no matter where they
live or how they like it is what makes
cereal griller a fun read especially
right now July 4th 2020 your message to
would-be grillers out there get outside
and grill first and foremost
we've been stuck inside for a long time
doing the responsible thing and I would
encourage people to just take the joy of
what that experience looks like there's
something magical about fire about the
smell that occurs and of course the
taste of the food and it doesn't matter
if you're grilling seafood or vegetables
or a big steak a tomahawk rib eye like I
probably have planned I just think it
just puts a smile on everybody's face
and you can of course get outside and
grill responsibly as well Misha I know
you weren't able to join this shoot
because you were on a you were on a
shoot yourself but we wanted to make
sure no one is left out here so we've
got Compton's something coming in for
you I believe as we speak look at that
from Marcy oh my god this is my
grandmother used to make this for me all
the time sheesh thank you so much oh
you're so welcome gonna say I'm in
grilling this is really a moment my
grandma better tastes as good as my
grandma's you're gonna make me cry too
that's really beautiful I'm so glad I'm
so glad you have that there please enjoy
it I'm sorry did I use in your ear yeah
I hear you
say say bye we thank Brian Toni Marcy
everybody involved in that entire shoot
that was that was nice